au moment où
le président tshisekedi
considère que les prisons macron est
l'interlocuteur de l'europe pour le
développement de l'afrique au moment où
nous commençons à sentir les effets de
la grande rencontre la grande conférence
qui s'est tenue à paris à l'initiative
du président mc ren le 18 mai dernier
pour la mobilisation d'un nouveau pacte
de relance pour l'afrique au moment où
les responsables politiques d'afrique du
sud après le déplacement du présent
macron à pretoria reconnaissent l'action
de la france pour lutter contre les
risques pandémiques et permet de la
production de vaccins à partir d'
afrique du sud au moment où au sénégal
on développe non seulement 1,9
universitaire franco sénégalais qui fait
l'admiration de tous mais au moment où
en relation avec le président macky sall
nous construisons une unité de
production de vaccin au moment où
nous y préparons un sommet entre l'union
européenne et l'union africaine sous
présidence française qui sera amené à
développer une nouvelle charte de la
relation entre l'europe et l'afrique oui
je peux continuer monsieur le président
karoutchi au moment où jamais il y a eu
au niveau de l'aide au développement un
effort aussi substantiel fait en
direction de l'afrique est reconnu par
tous y compris par cette propre
assemblée
au moment où au sahel nous sommes à la
tête d'une coalition regroupant 60 pays
dont une dizaine d'européens qui sont
convaincus que leur sécurité se joue
aussi la wii monsieur le présent
karoutchi il y a vraiment une politique
africaine de la france qui est reconnu
par beaucoup de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement mais aussi par les sociétés
africaines qui l'ont marqué lors du
sommet de montpellier il y a quelques
jours
oui il ya une politique africaine de la
france ce n'est pas la soirée la
françafrique peut-être que ça vous
dérange mais ce n'est plus la
françafrique voilà monsieur karoutchi
monsieur le président karoutchi
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre je veux vous
rassurer je ne suis pas nostalgique de
la françafrique mais au moment où nous
avons la chine afrique qui investit
massivement
à notre place souvent et qui obtient des
positionnements beaucoup plus lourd que
les nôtres au moment où la russe afrique
envoie les milices wagner et des
conseillers militaires dans des pays qui
étaient traditionnellement sous
influence française au moment où la
chine afrique remet au sénégal ou
ailleurs à djibouti des bases militaires
peut-être que la france doit se poser la
question de savoir quelle est la réalité
de sa relation je ne dis pas monsieur le
ministre que sa date de 3 4 ans je pense
que depuis dix ans depuis dix ans il ya
un doute sur ce que nous sommes censés
faire au niveau économique au niveau
financier regarder ce qui se passe avec
le franc cfa regardez ce qui se passe
avec nos investissements regarder ce qui
se passe avec les mouvements même
migratoires que nous avons du mal mais
celui de l'intérieur a à gérer oui il
faut revoir complètement la politique
française en afrique